hi guys happy birthday Jess she didn't
expect that one yes and I'm Serena yes
this is happening and we're going to
finish it let's do it
yay so this is I think our fourth plate
yeah um so you play this young boy
lucious who has the powers
sorry he's the son of the devil so he
has these powers and your goal so far
has been to kill people in your
household mother yeah she's cracking
basically there have been many murders
in the house the police are
investigating and it's really like
pretty bad how many people do you think
have died at this point it's an awful
lot all right gonna like eight yeah he
keeps this diary of pills as well one
two three four five six seven eight okay
nine ten eleven twelve tell you we kill
about 14 people in one chapter per death
we do hey jackass come you're very today
oh I got gasoline maybe uh maybe I'll
burn him to death okay what's this
chapter cold usually that's a giveaway
of what we're gonna do something about
fumes oh oh the car fumes No
oh really hello son
I'm so short should he be in the wall
like that yes that is how physics work
Lois is written in his diary yeah things
are going my way topic actually thinks
that will had something to do with
Michael's death he almost has a
personality here guys this is amazing
back with what's wrong with okay we just
killed two people in 17 minutes I think
that's pretty great
Wow will I just had coffee with him this
morning
why are we still here we should leave
now
by 1:00 it ain't a minute longer inside
this room someone said something
sensible stay away from Lucius it's
yours and ronamoon I'm going to wait for
you in the garden with our son bunnies
oh my god oh my god that's a reassuring
thing for a child to see whatever sort
oh my god Wow lemon Oh God
oh shoot it's a nail gun oh my god is
this body still there they didn't clean
that up yeah I have no [ __ ] idea
what's going on here what the [ __ ] just
happened
house has found evidence about something
and I didn't read it probably with who
kids let's get going and get like some
connected oh okay relax it's okay we got
this nice you're gonna make dad do it oh
my god okay lucious
off a few combining systems why are you
so complicated all right here yeah all
right come on you little jerk
yeah he's standing in my secret chamber
yeah that's pretty funny
getting [ __ ] you you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god wanna do all that again you
absolute crap game channel it controls
way than that it comes from this was
probably playing a really annoying game
as well so we supposed to hide from dad
not let him see us
I [ __ ] hate ya and then hide
hopefully all we need to do is mind
controlling from a distance and then
[ __ ] you Berger why the [ __ ] would you
even see me do I put the gun down first
no he'd only triggers after weight loss
whoa that's unfair oh I'm never gonna
make it back before he gets there just
run into him and do it I reckon okay
okay
you're controlling him learn it new you
cancelled him you may be a [ __ ] giant
it did work
did it work I don't know yes oh my god
okay I'm gonna celebrate - oh my god oh
my god is he gonna shoot them all oh my
god well she was never gonna last long
Hey look first person oh oh
gang him to shoot the crosses oh nice
what kind of cops is shoots us something
that moves like that it is funny Oh
helicopter fan
nice touch stay down you giant idiot why
wouldn't you own it
oh man alright let's take it to chat
okay fire a puzzle uh
I am inclined to go puzzle zareen wants
fire and it looks like it's puzzle
alright puzzle it is ahead by 10 let's
still got a load of fire the best
pomorie this would be fireless they'd be
protected by their cross head crosses
they gonna burn me know in a scary way
good sir I don't know how these things
are zapping into him because I'm not
doing it say to the guides child Satan
guides my chairs into my foes
probably dropped his cross sorry old man
slaying with fire
fit anyway oh my God he's actually using
that line priest Opie
well the priest in Wow huh [ __ ] you
[ __ ] come back you piece of [ __ ] Oh
what I get a game over you and you died
and I rule the world
man this game like got ahead of itself
it's like you're dead-on away in one
yeah
what so okay
dad is still here kill daddy
Oh Denton oh wow you disciplining
injection I actually see that I guess we
could just hate it can just bait him to
get him to stand next to you while
Shambo
and you just kill me can you move it's
really [ __ ] busy this is a [ __ ]
terrible ending the end is here
I think I died I'm outside no I think
that's the game bugging out this is the
waiter level singer level he's too small
waste runs away I don't understand
oh this is so annoying
why would you ever make a level that you
can fail in the first five seconds and
then have to wait until you get killed
to redo
can you miss Brighton illumines just
[ __ ] pick it up
he's not even under it pick up the bust
and move it to under the chandelier as
one suggestion does that work and now
it's like stuck in this corner ha ha yes
we realized that Buster's not spawning
where I supposed to I think the games a
little bit glitch right now daddy seems
to have lost his mind
oh my god daddy I think you Mike and
told him so many times this is losing it
what what
believe me is more frustrating to play
oh my gosh what what H Scott straight
away
what
okay you're so dead what the hell man
hey what he was on the phone and he gets
up straight away is this kid
I guess he just wanted to wait for
cutscene oh my god what is the
difference between that and every other
time that we did it oh [ __ ] oh my god
come on no oh my god whoo oh my god yeah
oh I straighten my tie like a [ __ ]
ball
so my shirts going all metallic um but
next week we're back at the same time I
have not yet decided what game we'll be
playing so if you have to just chill
maybe they'll be it's true do let us
know with a hashtag HOH lab in the
comments I don't you tube or GameSpot we
read them all